Two Americans
returning to
the US from Mexico after
their group was kidnaped last Friday
They had traveled there
so that Latvia,
Washington McGee
could undergo a medical procedur
Now, McGee is back in Texas
this morning uninjured.
Eric Williams was shot
three times in the leg.
The two others who were kidnaped
Saheed Woodward,
Woodard, I should say, and Tynda
Brown were sadly killed.
I want to bring in now Barbara
McLeod Burgess.
She is Latvia,
Washington, Mickey's mother.
Also with us
is Amani
Washington, Latvia's 13 year
old daughter,
and along with Latvia's
sons, Kadence McGee and Junior,
they are joining us
for their first live interview.
And I'm happy that you guys are
to bring light to this.
I'm sorry about what happened.
Barbara,
good morning to you and everyone
Have you spoken to Latvia?
And if so, how is she doing on
She is doing okay.
I talked to her last night.
Would you guys talk about it?
I thought she was done.
She was telling me that the host
and how they had it in their pla
and it was spent on her birthday
and almost hostage in the Pentag
and they were moving from place
Did she understand?
Did they understand
what was happening to them at th
No, because she said when is hed
there was going to end Taliban?
There she was driving to
a van, came up and hit him,
and that's when
they started shooting at the car
Shooting inside the van or whate
And I guess this is it.
The other was shot
at running and got shot at the s
Yeah. So I and
now that shot at the same time.
And she watched them.
She watched them die.
And you have to.
Rashid, right.
Who died?
Can you tell us about her? Yes.
Yes. I had
I had
his mother had passed away
when he was like 15.
And I had him ever since then.
And the
it was,
he was in the house
and so she takes her brother,
which is her cousin,
but it is her brother
and her cousin is my nephew and
And she was, she was the person.
And, you know, I miss them.
I love him
and nothing I wouldn't do for hi
Did you
were you watching
did you see the video of On the
Yes.
What was going through
your head when you saw
what?
A lot of bad stuff that
Amani just ran into my daughter
on that show us this.
Go on, Barbara.
Sorry you were saying what
not.
Especially when I saw
my daughter up on that shots ins
you just read up on like
like trash littered them on a ch
and not I didn't like it.
And I wanted to get to her.
Amani to her.
Amani, you saw it.
You must have
been worried about your mom.
What were you thinking?
I was just thinking why?
Why did they get kidnaped?
Stuff like that.
And
did you guys do either
of, you know, about
what happened and why?
Because they believe at this poi
that is a case of mistaken ident
Have they told you anything beyo
Have you spoken to authorities a
Barbara
about the kidnaping?
Yes, ma'am.
I talked to I talked to
someone who was to ask me
a question about
when at first, I guess after a d
after it happened.
And he was asking me something
about not to
ask me a question,
but to tell you that she was in
What are you hoping comes out of
I know I can't bring.
No one can bring your loved ones
But what are you hoping
happens from here?
Barbara,
I hope they get along and
and put them all in jail.
When it did it
put all on,
everyone on there has something
What? I want them not done.
You know,
Amani, did you have
you had a chance to speak to you
Yes.
What did you talk about?
Almost all I did was say, hey,
it's over now.
I missed her,
and I was ready for her to come
You know,
listen, I don't
I can't begin to imagine
when families
go through situations like this
and your whole life is sort of
put on display in front of every
I know that that is disconcertin
but to have someone die
and then get on television
and talk about it,
at least members of your family,
your mom and your daughter didn'
But it's got to be tough for you
Can you explained,
Barbara,
what your family
is going through at this moment?
I don't know.
I know that is her and this is h
it because of what happened to S
which he died and my neck and ne
So I know it is.
I heard about everything.
This is Barbara.
I understand
the second time
that your daughter
went down
to the area in Mexico
for a medical procedure.
Did she at any point before
say that she felt unsafe about i
No.
No, she didn't you know,
she didn't come in and out.
She was.
Did you know?
Listen,
the CDC
is warning against medical proce
outside of the country.
They are calling it a level four
The State Department is.
Do you have a message for other
who may be considering
the same thing, Barbara?
No arrest lists
that are not safe for the family
That was no like the other famil
I would know there is
is her and feeling
no sad and stuff about it.
You know,
and some of the people out in Am
all the details.
How are you guys?
Are you guys going to go to you?
Are you going to Texas or what?
How are you going to do it?
Is she going to come home?
Latvia
are you going to go see
or is to wait until she comes ho
Oh,
we'll wait until she come home.
She's supposed to come home toda
You know
what?
Anything you want to say before
I let you guys go?
Because I can see that that J.R.
and Cadence are getting restless
Yeah.
Oh, I got to say is that they
find my mom and
that's it.
Yeah, I should say Junior.
So
thank you so much
for joining us, Barbara.
Thank you, Amani.
Thank you, Cadence. Thank you, J
Mm hmm.
You guys as well as you can
under these circumstances. You a
So you're welcome.
So you were actually welcome.
Thank.